there was a time when American colleges
were hives of free speech and
independent thought that was a long time
ago now they're famous for tolerating no
dissent whatsoever speak out as a
student you can be suspended or flunked
or insidiously speak out as a professor
you'll be threatened or fired trying to
bring new ideas to campus you'll provoke
a riot we saw that last year UC Berkeley
won my leg innopolis visited
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
most campuses are pretty bad the
question is one of the worst well re
cones been keeping track he's a lawyer
for the foundation for individual rights
in education fire he joins us tonight
all right thanks for coming up so one of
the worst schools not for free speech
well it's a wide field every year when
we look at what schools earn their place
on the list and I think boy how could it
get any crazier end up kicking myself
but let's start with UC Berkeley the the
college that really kind of kicked it
off at the beginning of last year where
a presentation by Miley innopolis was
cancelled after protesters took the
streets and overwhelmed the police and
committed property damage and violence
and ended up just causing an enormous
amount of mayhem and they did you see UC
Berkeley has kind of trying to been on
the mend since then they've paid an
enormous amount of money for various
free speech events although not without
allegations that they first tried to
stifle and censor that speech they paid
about eight hundred thousand dollars for
Ben Shapiro I believe and they're
currently facing a lawsuit regarding a
speech that was planned by Ann Coulter
and David Horowitz where the Department
of Justice has recent filed the
statement of interest so it says
policies so we followed that pretty
carefully at Harvard on the list you got
Drexel on the list white Drexel well
Drexel a professor tweeted a in his
words satirical and joking tweet
regarding white genocide all I want for
Christmas is white genocide poking fun
at the idea that white genocide is a
thing that exists and somewhat
predictably the internet erupted in
outrage with calls for his firing and he
was suspended and investigated by Drexel
and had to actually keep himself off
campus because Drexel said that the
environment was not safe for him
eventually said I can't come back and
teach here this is not going to work
unbelievable so let me ask you a quick
question though so you study this stuff
for a living if you had
it's about to go to college would you
want to send them to any college and if
so where would you want to send them
well first thing I would do would be go
to fires website and look up our speech
code ratings and see which schools are
protecting their students expressive
rights public or private yeah and then
go and look and see what kind of
controversies have happened on campus
I'm pretty sure that I want my children
to feel free to associate with the
people they want to associate with and
not be told who they can and cannot be
friends with Harvard it needs to be a
free country all right thanks a lot for
joining us tonight